no no absolutely not i mean it to but
the two-party system is really a
one-party system you could call the DA
mulliken party or the Republic red party
take your pick everyone knows I'm
telling the truth about this you know at
the top that you know look where we are
we're at war both parties have supported
the war even though the Democrats that
you vote Democrat will get you out of
Iraq right here we are a year later both
parties support the oil companies
otherwise you've got a windfall profit
tax both parties support the insurance
companies otherwise you'd have a
not-for-profit health care system so
when you look at some of the key
economic issues that Americans have you
know both parties support these
multinational corporations otherwise you
wouldn't have all these jobs laws now
the mythology is well vote Democrat
you'll have your job will be protected
no because the Democrats brought you
naft in China trade so you know you my
candidacy is about changing the
direction of the Democratic Party it's
about having a real democratic party as
opposed to a fake version of the
Democratic Party and and people know
that their choices are being limited so
should there be more choices look I'm a
green Democrat i'm an independent
Democrat in some ways I'm a libertarian
Democrat because I stand up for people's
basic constitutional rights don't forget
you know Democrats in the Senate help
pass the Patriot Act you know one
candidate for president bragged then
about how he was the co-author of it so
let's have a real difference between the
parties and let's have a real debate if
you don't have that we absolutely have
to have more more political parties
you